from time immemorial humanity has
pondered perhaps the biggest question of
all
how did life begin
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
the answer to this question has tested
the bounds of science and even sometimes
bordered on metaphysics
in fact one of the most famous
investigations
into the origin of life is the miller
yuri experiment
which attempted to simulate the
conditions of the purported
primordial earth it succeeded in
creating proto-organic amino acids
from inorganic compounds electricity
heat and
other ingredients this result is
controversial
but it's cute to note that it had a
connection to where i am right now at uc
san diego
in fact the yuri is related to
yuri hall who is the namesake of our
chemistry department here at uc san
diego
now don't get too excited i'm not going
to speculate and say i believe
i understand the answer to it as a
cosmologist i will point down however
that it's one of my favorite chicken or
egg
type questions and maybe even relates to
the so-called
great debates that i speak about in
losing the nobel prize
namely the great debate center around
how
central humanity is in the organization
of our solar system
of our galaxy maybe of our universe and
perhaps
the multiverse as this video over here
took us and explored but today i'm
raising another chicken or egg type
question
just as mysterious which came first the
literal chicken
or the egg namely the genetic material
or the organism that produces
the organic chemistry that we then
sprung forth
now an intrinsic component of the
mystery of life
is why do the building blocks of life
exhibit a property
a type of symmetry or asymmetry known as
chirality
or handedness most living things exhibit
bilateral symmetry
such as the fact that your left half and
your right half look mainly
identical or the wings of a bird have a
twofold symmetry
or there might be a five-fold symmetry
in a sea star
and maybe an eight-fold symmetry in a
spider
now since you can flip a symmetrical
object
about a mirror axis and it looks the
same with respect to left and right
handedness
then you might wonder if there's
anything intrinsically important
about the fact that life is based upon
building blocks which themselves are
chiral
from where does this chirality emerge
chiral objects do not superimpose
properly
when flipped your right hand and your
left hand exhibit this property
of symmetry apparently but you can't put
a right hand
into a left-handed glove even if you
flip it around backwards
chiral asymmetry occurs at the molecular
scale too
a molecule can have the same atoms the
same two-dimensional and
three-dimensional structure
but if flipped one way versus the other
way it cannot be superimposed
the two molecules are called anathemas
or opposite images a very famous example
of such a molecule
is the drug called thalidomide it is an
example
of a chiral molecule that was once used
to treat nausea
in women during pregnancy the right hand
molecular version
or isomer of this particular compound
thalidomide
did just that it cured nausea but the
right-handed version
also led to horrific birth defects if
you're watching this and you're alive
then you're a living organism that is
replete with chiral molecules
not only is it true of molecular
structure but it can be true down to the
helical structure
of ribonucleic acid and dna as well
these can twist to the right or to the
left with equal probability
and yet the helix of dna of
living organisms on earth turn only to
the right
sometimes called the live direction the
bioavailable
sugars that are used in the consumption
for molecular
energy are also right-handed
and in fact that is exploited sometimes
for certain weight loss products
as well this chirality of molecules and
even of rna and dna has fascinated
some of the greatest scientific minds of
all time including louis pasteur
who was one of the first to observe it
legendary chemist and writer primo levy
had a lifelong fascination with this
question
what is it about the universe that
created handedness
in life itself on earth we know of no
other organisms throughout the universe
that have
dna that we could compare so perhaps
it's a one-off effect
but perhaps it is a constituent of the
building blocks of matter
itself could the riddle of life's
chirality
be hidden or related to the nature of
chirality
in elementary particle physics well
first clue could be in the nature of
that perpetual annoyance
dust now it does seems to fascinate me
and it is the villain of my book losing
the nobel prize
but it is not the dust that seems to
spontaneously regenerate on your
furniture
dragged by your toddler or feature
prominently in
pictures from the voyager satellite the
famous pale blue dot image
that carl sagan commanded the voyager 1
spacecraft to take on valentine's day
1990 but some of the dust falls to earth
and some of that dust from
micrometeorites coming from our solar
system
contains traces of amino acids and some
of these amino acids on the dust that
falls to earth
have more content more versions and more
examples
of left-handed versions of amino acids
radio telescopes like this one
have detected chiral molecules in deep
space
so these images reveal properties of
chirality
throughout our known universe and yet we
only have one example
the so-called right-handed helix of dna
on earth on the only living systems that
we know about
now asymmetries are also present at the
foundations of physics
at the highest energies that emanate in
our cosmos
could these chiral differences in the
fundamental nature
of elementary particles influenced the
formation
of chirality in molecules and even dna
on earth
so one of the earliest links to life on
earth as i said
and the chiral nature of molecules was
observed by louis pasteur
one of the first scientists to recognize
the asymmetry
lee and yang in the 1950s predicted a
certain fundamental force called the
weak force would be
chiral so-called cp violation takes
place
and was famously observed by madame c.s
wu
later on just a few years later at
columbia university
i study the cmb the cosmic microwave
background the remnant
ancient fossil heat left over from the
formation of the elements
emanating from a time when hydrogen
first formed in the early universe
after the big bang
this fossil light can exhibit a type of
chirality violation
as well and asymmetry is revealed by its
polarization
in fact one of the goals of the simon's
observatory that i co-lead
is to detect the subtle swirl with
profound
implications in cosmology not the
ordinary b mode signal that would be
indicative of an early
inflationary event that we spoke about
in this video
but an actual cp violation in the early
universe
as traced by the so-called forbidden
polarization patterns
that i talked about with sean carroll in
this video here recently two
astrophysicists including naomi globus a
high-energy astrophysicist
at new york university and the center
for computational astrophysics in the
flatiron institute
he teamed up with roger blandford a
fellow astrophysicist at stanford
and theorized that cosmic rays may
explain the biological homochirality
or the preference for right-handedness
via the phenomenon
of the four fundamental forces of nature
we talk about familiar forces like
gravity and electromagnetism all the
time
we experience them every day via
electromagnetic light or gravity when
you drop something
but there are also two other forces that
are much less familiar that at different
energies are expected to unify with
these two other lower energy forces
including the strong atomic force which
binds nuclei together
and the weak force which is responsible
for radioactive decay
now it turns out that the weak force
exhibits chirality
so when cosmic rays break up in the
atmosphere of earth
they produce particles called pions
pions
slamming into the atmosphere produce
showers of particles including electrons
and their heavier siblings called muons
all of which
are driven and impacted by the chiral
weak force
globus and blanford theorized that over
millennia the effect on molecules
may have been to impact right-handed
ones just a bit more than their
evil sinister left-handed ones just to
drive evolution slightly more in that
direction
however not everybody agrees with this
assumption
take professor lee cronin the regis
professor at the university of glasgow
a renowned chemist and inventor he has
this to say about the globus blanford
proposal
um chirality is really interesting
phenomena obviously when we talk about
fundamental
particles chirality is an intrinsic
feature
of many of these
and the individual particle can be seen
as a function of its spin associated you
can call these chiral
when we're talking about molecules
however it's a little bit different i'm
a chemist
so molecule for me is a collection of
atoms held together
by strong interactions that we might
call bonds
and those bonds um are typically hard to
break
so that means when i stick atoms
together and i do it let's just imagine
i was doing it precisely
like an architect those atoms would
generally speaking
their rotation and movement but the
relative
orientation or position if you like
atoms with regard to each other
and when you're able to put atoms
together in a molecule
using covalent bonds organic chemists
typically would
draw these molecules and under certain
conditions
if you have a number of at different
atoms around the central molecule
you could call that a chiral center you
also can have chiral
planes so molecules can be
kyle with respect to the atom twisted
there's two really interesting schools
of thought there are people that are
going to look for life in the universe
and one one signature that people were
saying might be really interesting
is to look for a chiral excess a large
chiropractor
has been postulated to be a unique
signature for life there's another
school
which says okay um for life to emerge
one of the critical ingredients we need
is a chiral excess so we have to have a
chiral excess
before life is started before the origin
and so we have this classic problem
built here
is life chiral
because of the stuff at the beginning or
is life able to produce chirality
from an ostensibly racemic world or
perhaps a
world where there's just a very slight
excess i would argue that actually life
produces chirality in fact life doesn't
even need an excess
indeed it's clear that there are
excesses of chiral
molecules found in meteorites people
have made a conjecture
that may be the irradiation of the
interstellar medium
via circularly polarized light or some
other
uh certain circumference hdv light
probably will cause deep selective
decomposition
of one hand of the molecules with
respect to the other it's not clean
it's in small amounts but nevertheless
it appears to be
a a fairly sound
observation now go into the lab coupled
with the
the observation that chemists have found
they are able to see
experiments which normally would produce
you know
a racemic outcome but if you see it and
you put in slight excess you can bias
that
particularly if there's catalysis and
i'm gonna to try and suggest
that the the life produces chirology and
actually chirality is probably an
emergency property in physics
it it's a natural thing that comes out
of how
mata interacts in space but
chirality can be an emergent phenomena
when you have networks of interacting
molecules
then at some point when it starts
interacting in the environment and
selection occurs
that selection starts to produce
chiral structure having a consistent
twist on those
on the building blocks would allow the
part seems to give the polymers the
ability to fold
into objects and those objects have more
stability because they're all
complementary the helices fit together
and it's really rather nice and you have
a way of getting to a very
complex configuration space without
having to search all the space
so what i'm saying is that chirality is
produced by selection
and as selection starts to kind of boot
up
that you start to store information and
as you start to record
the presence in the environment and that
information storage
needs chirality to search a higher
dimensional space
to get advantage and that's where good
life
produces chirality chirality is not on
off it is the accretion of information
through selection and we need to think
about it in that
more nuanced way stay tuned for a
special interview
with professor cronin following this
video's airing
in the tradition of miller and uri david
dreamer a biochemist at the university
of california
santa cruz has designed an apparatus
developed to mimic the conditions on the
early earth
and he plans to test the cosmic ray
theory by bombarding a bacterial colony
of microbes with beams of chiral
electrons or muons
and determine if that will result in
preferred mutations
what we're trying to do in the
laboratory is to simulate a process
that we think was very common on the
early earth
and it's still common today in fact
whenever rain falls in a volcano
it makes little puddles that are heated
by the volcanic
energy in the laboratory we are
simulating that by building a chamber
the chamber has got to be anaerobic
meaning there's can't be any air in it
and
every vial that is embedded in this disc
and there's 24 of them
goes through one wet dry cycle every
90 minutes we're drying it out under a
stream of carbon dioxide
we're rehydrating with just plain old
water then it goes through another
drying cycle
this occurs every 90 minutes and in a
typical experiment
we'll have about four of these cycles
in a day that we will then analyze the
result
and see what we've made if anything luca
legeniani of the blackman laboratory
here in san diego
at the scripps institute is pursuing
another research path demonstrating how
very small initial chiral changes
can drive a dominant form of chirality
under lab conditions
that are thought to mimic evolutionary
processes
click here for that video to learn more
about luca's experiment
so the big question of how life began
may remain a mystery for now
but the twisted nature of the universe
may be hinting to a direction that's
worth pursuing
i'm brian keating chancellor's
distinguished professor of physics and
co-director of the arthur c clark center
for human imagination
thanking you for watching this episode
of into the impossible
stay tuned for more great conversations
[Music]
you